περιπτώσει τις ναρκωτικώ όπως και σε συνεργασία με τη γρόπο γιατί γρο πολί να κί
μας εξήπηρετα ηαστυνομία κύπρου κατάφερε να εντοποίσει κάποιες αγορα πολισί ν αρκωτικά και με τη
αν προχωρήσαμε σε έρευνα και σύληψη ατό άρά και εμείς σαναστυνομία καταπέραμε την μπήκαμεμέσα χουμ
τες παρακολουθούμε τω σκοτεινώ δείκτιων διαδείκτηκο καιυπάρχουν κάποιο ελεδματα αλλά αυτό που είναι εμειονεκτικώ είναι
ότι δεν υπάρχει τωθού πολύ προσωπικώ για ανα σχοείτι εντατικά αυό που θέλουμε εί είναι
να υξήσουμε την την παρατήρηση τη θα υπερπατρόλεση νεκεταί ταστον κόθμα μας μας να απτύξουμε
το προσωπικό που ν μπόρει να παρακολουθώ αυτά ταγιεγονότα α να πουρ έχουν να έχουμε
ακόμα περισότερα αποτελεσματα θα πάωκαι στις συνέχεια στο σκοτενα διανίκτιο θέλω πρώτα ξεκινήσουμε λίγο με
αυτές τις απάτης παίρνουμε σε διάφορες πλατφόρομε στο κινητό μας μήνυμα ότι ολογαριασμός μας θέλει
μια ανταυτωποίη συστοιχίο τό ποιο συχνό εγώ προσωπικά δεν εκακό να δομό σας πύρα διοτρεις
φορές να ς πω έλαβα αυτό το μήνυμααντι να κάνω και τις περισσότερες μου είπες
εναι ιώς μην το ανοίξεις ορίς υτό είναι στην καθημερινό ήταν μας πλέον να έχουμε
ένια αυτές τις απάτες οι διικάσει ότε αφορά προσωπικά εδομένα όπως είναι η λογαριασμή μας
στις τράπεζας για παραδι ναι αυτό συμβέτι πρέπει να καταδουνήσουμε ότι δε συμπαίντεια τομικά είναι
σε μαζική υπάρχουν σε άλλες χώρες κυρίος σασία καιαφρικί υπάρχει θαν εργοστα θα που ιοποίηση
όλα ν αυτόν των των τακτικό μιλάτή φεύγουν μαζικά μηνήματα ακριβώ ς καιο οποιο αντλούν
στοιχία από τοσκοτεινό διαδείκτιο όπως είπαμε δι των το ελεκτρονικόν ποταχιδρομίον το ηλεκτρονικό μου